Hello, did you hear the news?
“DALL-E 2 has a secret language”!
If one lets DALLE-2 generate an image from
"Apoploe vesrreaitais", it will generate birds.
"Contarra ccetnxniams luryca
tanniounons" generates bugs or pests.
Ms. Coffee Bean, are you drunk?
In this video, we will discuss what the
discoverers of this phenomenon have told us
on Twitter and in their arXiv paper about this.
We will see what theories the community has
come up with to explain how DALLE-2 can
generate sensible output from gibberish.
And we will realize that we should guard ourselves
from the incoming flood of clickbait headlines,
because spoilers, but no: DALL-E
2 does not have an own “language”.
Language or not, DALL-E 2’s gibberish
is an interesting phenomenon to look at,
nonetheless, so let’s discuss
this in an AI Coffee Break!
But before we dive in, let’s thank
Weights&Biases for supporting us in this video!
Today, we are discussing DALL-E 2 from
OpenAI that generates images from text.
Only that the code and weights
for this model are not released.
But DALL-E Mini and DALL-E Mega are
open source projects by Boris Dayma
that replicate OpenAI’s efforts.
And the cool thing is that Boris
used Weights & Biases Reports to
track and communicate his progress!
Of course, because W&B Reports
are incredibly flexible,
allowing to communicate your work to
colleagues, managers or even just yourself!
In this Report, Boris is keeping a training
journal of how his latest model training is going,
which he updates regularly with
notes about new experiments
and changes to the model’s
training regime that he’s trying.
Reports are a great tool for education and sharing
analysis, for your colleagues or the wider world.
The Report here is more polished that the previous
one and contains educational graphics
as well as interactive Weights & Biases
charts and Tables to help the reader
understand the results of his work.
Finally, for those of us with not enough time,
Report are a perfect way to create a concise, real
time and high level dashboard for a more focused
summary of how a project or model is doing.
Go to wandb.me/ai-coffee-break to explore
and interact with these Reports yourself and
see how Reports can help you share your
work with colleagues around the world!
Ok, so here is the news. We have this
text-to-image generation model DALL-E 2
from OpenAI. It’s a diffusion model that can
take in text and produce an amazing picture.
If you are interested in how
text-to-image diffusion models work,
check out our previous videos on this!
But now, here’s the catch: DALL-E 2 can not only
take in sensible input text and produce
its best shots at an image from this,
but no. It can take in gibberish and
produce output that looks really good.
And even more, it seems like this “gibberish”
does mean something for the model because the
combination of something that produces
birds with something that produces bugs,
in "Apoploe vesrreaitais eating
Contarra ccetnxniams luryca tanniounons"
gives images of birds eating
bugs! Is this language?
No, it is not, as the authors have quickly
realized after announcing their findings on
Twitter and changed their paper title from
“secret language” to “secret vocabulary”.
Language has syntax and grammar, but DALL-E
2 seems rather to respond at gibberish words.
So how did the authors find and generate
such examples? It seems like the discovery
happened while the authors were playing with
the text rendering capabilities of DALL-E 2.
The model is already known to
produce very weird results on this.
So, they gave the model an input
where it had to produce text, like
"Two farmers talking about vegetables, with
subtitles" and found that the produced text
is not as random as one might think.
This word “Vicootess” produces dishes
with vegetables, and “apoploe
vesrreaitars” produces birds.
So the authors concluded that the farmers must be
talking about birds messing with their vegetables.
In this thread, you can see other examples too,
but what we see there and in the paper are not
really many examples and it is a bit unclear
on what the success rate of this method is.
Sometimes it works, sometimes it
doesn’t as highlighted in this thread,
where only 4 out of 10 examples generate
sports from the word “tiboer”, even though,
like in the farmers example, those two men speak
about “tiboer” which seems to be about sports.
So why does this even happen that DALL-E
2 generates good looking pictures from
gibberish? The authors make the fuzzy claim
that the model has internally developed a
hidden “language”, ahm, we mean “vocabulary”
after being trained on image-text pairs!
Well, this is not very specific,
so let’s look at the theories
circulating on Twitter right now, because
there are a few very interesting ones:
The first one I saw was by Joscha Bach.
He points out that the text generations
are quite inconsistent. In the paper,
the authors prompt DALL-E 2 with “"Two
whales talking about food, with subtitles",
but Joscha Bach points out that the “secret words”
one gets from this, are different every time.
So, Joscha Bach goes on saying that the
secret words are just random strings that
sometimes point to consistent regions the
embedding space. The model projects the
samples into a high dimensional space
and clusters neighboring concepts.
Then honestly, I do not get what the
rest of the explanation wants to say,
maybe you know, so go to the
comments and explain if you want.:)
So here is Ms. Coffee Bean’s take on this,
which might be very different from
the one in this thread, sorry.
The model has a limited number of
parameters and for efficiency reasons,
it needs to cluster the space of words well,
so concepts that are related to one another,
should be close in this space. Since
we are working with neural networks,
the text it represented as continuous
vectors, but surprise! Text is discrete
and is composed of words that do not have
an in-between as a continuous vectors do.
And since the model always must produce an output,
whatever the input, the in-between words,
so gibberish will also produce an output.
As it turns out, this is sometimes
consistent between the string input
and rendered text in the image.
How seldom this works and how inconsistent this
is, is highlighted by another twitter user, who
points out that the bug producing prompt does
not produce so many bugs or pests after all,
since we in DALL-E 2’s generations, we
also have animals like deer and goats.
Still along the line of the
discreteness of language are
the opinions that say that the “secret
language” is mostly due to tokenizers
effects since “Apo-didae & Plo-ceidae are
families of birds, each with 100+ species.
Apo-diformes is the biggest order of
birds with 400+ species of birds.”
So the model has connected the
“apo” and “plo” subwords to birds.
Somebody else found that one can infer some of
these sub-words that will work with DALL-E 2 by
looking at Wikipedia, where “Actinopterygii"
and "Placodermi" are two families of fish.
And then "placoactin knunfidg"
generates fish images.
You know, with neural networks,
sometimes it is great input in,
garbage out. Now it is gibberish
in, quality images out!
It’s clear that we do not yet understand these
black boxes and unless some more rigorous
interpretability goes into these models,
we will continue prompting in the dark.
It’s important to highlight that as long
as we are surprised by this weird way of
communication from DALL-E 2 and similar models,
we are also ignorant of some security issues:
Adversarial attacks with these gibberish
prompts, as well as not-so-gibberish prompts
can trigger unwanted behavior from models,
circumventing filters on the allowed inputs.
It’s clear that so far, these models do not
behave like humans would expect them to,
and malicious humans could take advantage of this.
What do you think about this? Would you
interested to enroll in Ms. Coffee
Bean’s DALL-E 2 language classes?
See you next time! Okay, bye!